Voiceover:In the last video,
we were able to model the average
high temperature in Santiago, Chile
as a function of days
as we go through the year,
where the days were the days
after January 7th,
so this right over here.
Day zero is actually January 7th.
But we weren't done.
They want us to figure out
how many days after January 7th
is the first spring day,
when the temperature reaches
20 degrees celsius
And I told you, be careful.
Pay attention to this whole notion
of the first spring day
and the reason is because there's actually
two days where the temperature reaches
20 degrees celsius,
So let's say this is 20 degrees celsius
right over here,
notice you have this day right over here
and then you have this
day right over there
and which one is in the spring
or the first spring day?
Well, if this is -
we're in summer right over here
We're in the southern hemisphere,
so our summer is going to be
when it is the winter
in the northern hemisphere.
Summer, what season comes after summer?
Well, this is going to be the fall,
this is going to be the winter,
Now this is going to be the spring.
Of course, you go back to summer.
So, we want this value,
not this value.
This one will be the day in fall
when the average high temperature
is 20 degrees celsius,
This is the first day of spring
where the average high temperature
is 20 degrees celsius.
The first spring day.
I guess it's not necessarily
the first spring day,
it's the first spring day
where the temperature
reaches 20 degrees celsius.
So, this is happening in the spring,
so this is the value we want.
So, let's just think about that.
As we try to manipulate this a little bit.
So, we want to get to 20 degrees celsius,
so we could write 20 is equal to
7.5 times cosine of 2 pi over 365
times the days,
plus 21.5
Now, we could subtract
21.5 from both sides
and we get -1.5 is equal to-
and I'll just copy and paste all of this-
is going to be equal to that.
So, copy and paste.
It's going to be equal
to that right over there.
Now I could divide both sides by 7.5.
Notice, I'm trying to solve for cosine,
and eventually solve for D,
but we're going to take a pause,
once we have this in terms of cosine,
we have to be careful here.
So we're going to divide both sides by 7.5
And we're going to get, let's see...
Actually, I don't even need
a calculator for this..
1.5 divided by 7 -
this is one fifth.
5 times 15, or 5 times 1.5 is 7.5
so this is -1/5
or I could write it as -0.2 is equal to
cosine of 2 pi over 365
times days after January 7th.
Now, this is where we
have to be very careful
instead of just blindly applying
the inverse cosine function,
we have to make sure which angle
we are actually getting.
That we're getting the
right angle over here.
'Cause remember, we want the argument
to the cosine,
that doesn't give us this point,
that gives us this point right here.
Or that corresponds to this
point right over there.
So let's draw a unit circle,
just to make sure we know what's going on.
And I actually do this all the time,
especially if I'm trying to apply
the inverse trigonometric functions
in a kind of applied context,
where I just can't blindly plug it in
to my calculator.
So, let me draw a unit
circle right over here.
X-axis, y-axis...
Circle of radius 1, centered at the origin
You get the picture
we've done this many times before.
And January 7th, that corresponds
to this point right over here.
That's that point right over here,
that we are in the summer.
Then, as the days go by,
our argument to the cosine increases,
the angle increases,
and this right over here
will be the fall.
So, this point right over here,
so we're at the fall right over here.
And then we move on to the winter
right over there.
And then finally, we go to the spring.
This is the spring right over there.
And we want the angle that gets us -0.2
So, this is -1.
-0.2 is a fifth of the way,
so it's -0.2 and notice,
there's two angles that get us there.
There's this angle,
there's that angle right over there.
And then there's also,
let me draw a little dotted line here,
there's that angle.
But then there's also this angle.
which is going even further.
Or another way you could think about it,
you could go backwards
to get to that angle
and then if you wanted
to go all the way around,
to the next spring,
you could add 2 pi to it.
So which one do we want?
Of course, we want the one in the spring.
But if we just blindly
apply the inverse cosine,
of -0.2, that's going to give us this one.
And we can verify that. So, let's see...
Inverse cosine of -0.2 is 1.77.
Remember, this is zero,
this is pi right over, so this is 3.14159,
and this is 1.77,
so notice it's a little
bit more than half of pi
which is exactly what it gave-
it gave this angle right over here.
So this is approximately 1.77 radiants
is this angle, is that
angle right over there.
But we don't want that one,
we want this one,
so how do we figure that out?
Well, we could view it as,
we could go all the way around to 2 pi,
and then subtract 1.77,
so we could say 2 pi minus 1.77 roughly
to get this angle, so let's do that.
Let's take 2 times pi,
and then subtract this number
and I'm going to do second answer,
so answer is just the
previous answer that I got
so that way I have good precision here.
So I get 4.511,
and we can kind of make
sure that is the right thing
because that's going to be between
pi and 2 pi.
2 pi is 2 times 3.14159,
so it's going to be
6.28 something.
This is 3.14159,
this is the right angle.
Now, we're not done yet.
That's just the angle,
that's the argument that we need to give
in here to get to that point,
but what's the days going to be.
Well 2 pi over 365 days is going to be
equal to this number 4.511,
so let me write that down.
So, this right over here is going to be
approximately equal to 4.511.
So, we scroll down a little bit
We can say 2 pi over 365
times the days after January 7th
is approximately going
to be equal to 4.511
to solve for days,
we can just multiply both sides
by the reciprocal of the coefficient,
so we're going to multiply both sides
by 365 over 2 pi.
So that's going to cancel,
and now we can use our
calculator for this.
So, we've got much better precision there.
So let's take our previous answer,
times 365, we deserve a drumroll here...
Divided by 2 pi, and we get
if we round to the nearest day
262 days after January 7th.
So 262 days. and we are done.